there's this one in this video and he
was saying how other test subjects
besides 11 like 1-10
he says that most of them are dead but
others were like banished to the upside
down like they couldn't get out and
because they were in the upside down for
so long and you can see that it had an
effect on will it had an effect on them
because they were in it for so long that
they transformed into what was the
monster so the monster was a recent test
subject so stranger things season 4 is
the first entry in the series to be
split up into two parts on july 1st
we're going to be getting the second
volume with the final two episodes
dropping the same day these are going to
be super sized with the first being an
hour and 25 minutes long and the finale
is coming in at an incredible two and a
half hours longer than my last
relationship this is gonna have the run
time of most marvel and star wars tv
shows and they have a lot of things that
they can do in them throughout this
video i want to give our theories on
where we think things will be going
whilst also going over some spoilers
from part one no idea why you're here if
you've not seen her but on the off
chance you got the watch order of the
prediction video before the last season
upside down then this is your last
chance to check out before we do a deep
dive on the entire thing if you're still
here thanks for sticking with me now
let's turn it up to 11 and get into
stranger things season 4 volume 2. now
the first major thing that comes from
the end of volume 1 is that i think it
confirms 11 gets her powers back early
on in the season we heard dr owens
talking about how he thinks the nina
project will revitalize her abilities
and help in the upcoming war in the
series we learn that this is through a
giant machine with a floatation device
in the middle that is equipped with
television screen so that the person
inside of it can view recordings you
learn that this name comes from the
opera of the same name created by
nicholas dalairak
now this piece is basically about a
woman who discovers that her lover was
killed during a duel and in order to
save herself the pain of this her brain
buried the memory inside her
subconscious completely hiding the
trauma she believed him to be alive and
would venture out to a train station
every day believing that he would return
the truth of the matter was hidden from
her by herself due to the anguish that
came from it and this is very similar to
11 who lost her powers after the events
of season 3. nina is very much about her
taking a trip into her subconscious to
discover the truth about her past and to
also showcase to her how she gained her
abilities in the first place this not
only gives us the truth about beckner
but it's also basically going through
the motions once more so that she can
remember how to tap into her abilities
now because eleven manages to do this
and the season ends with us coming full
circle from how it starts off i do
believe that this means her powers are
now back in taking a trip down memory
lane and to going through all the paces
of the nina project she has finally
rediscovered them so i think they come
next time my number one prediction put
it in writing eleven will get her powers
back make sure you stay tuned for more
amazing predictions clearly spelled out
in the show i promise the video gets
better not by much but it does now
because of this i think that we are
obviously leading to a showdown between
wekner and eleven the pair's history was
set up really well in this season and it
ended with eleven basically transforming
him into the freddie krugers monster
that he became he'll no doubt want
revenge and we discover in the season
that he's the five star general for the
main player with the next season being
the final one i think that part two will
end with a big battle between the pair
we discovered in this season that there
are ways to at least escape him and this
comes from having love for something the
series was very much about people who
were distant from each other coming back
together and this motif was shown in
mike in 11 lucas and max joyce and
hopper dustin and his girlfriend steven
nancy and so on and so forth i think
that everyone will reunite for part two
and this will be what empowers 11 to
have enough energy to take vechna down
once and for all in the teaser we also
catch eddie thrashing away in the upside
down so it seems like the love for an
item or object will be used heavily to
take him out now because of the way that
part 1 ended i actually think that we'll
pick up immediately on the other side of
this and that will catch him in the
upside down as he comes face to face
with the mind flayer we discovered that
vekna was obsessed with black widow
spiders as a child and with the mind
flayer resembling one of these he will
likely start to worship him i'd
absolutely love to see his journey
through the upside down and we could
also learn what shaped it in this season
we discover that it's stuck in 1983 like
uncle rico from napoleon dynamite and
that it's not changed since the day well
by has entered it now because of this i
think the entire reality works much in
the same way that the dark dimension
does in doctor strange this was a
completely formless universe but upon
strange entering it it started to
somewhat mirror him in the behind the
scenes stories on the production of the
film the creative team talked about how
they cast benedict cumberbatch's
dormammu to show that the villain very
much crafted his appearance of the first
person he came across i think the upside
down will likely be similar to this and
that it starts to alter the way it looks
to seem similar to hawkins because
that's all it knows from the right side
up perhaps wekner will also help
introduce this as well as he's from our
reality and thus he can inform its
appearance this would explain why the
creel house exists down there too
because it's something that he knows
from the real world so prediction
forgot to do one for the last one so
predictions two and three eleven versus
wekner and wekner in the upside down
explain make sure you had explained it's
good for seo now the series also ended
with nancy being stuck down there with
him in the scene we watched as she
attempted to climb from the upside down
into the right side up and it's at this
moment that she was pulled across curtis
steve shouting in her face unable to
wake her which is when max realizes
what's going on to make matters worse
the season actually ends with her stuck
down there with beckner but there is a
clue as to how they'll get her out at
one point in the season robin goes
through nancy's things when they're at
her house this happens in episode 4 a
roughly the 10 minute mark during it she
comes across a music box that springs
open and then shows directly to me
pointed at me and she says put this in
your theory video because it's theory
time third time third time so i think
that this scene will come back around
and that robin will end up using the
music box to pull nancy out of the
upside down
can we put that on screen and text as
well robin uses music box to pull nancy
out however i do think that during her
visit to the upside down that she'll
discover wekner's true plan and i think
right that to him he's doing things for
the right reasons hold on a second i'll
explain now the guy clearly has a
twisted view of the world and this was
something that he developed earlier in
his life the back story we get treated
to a creel house very much tells us all
we need to know about him and his goals
beckon abuse humans as people stuck in
routine constantly counting the seconds
minutes and hours until their death he
views everything as a massive waste of
time and talks about how he is very much
trying to wipe out humanity because of
what he deems as being destructive to
the planet however the people that he
kills all share something in common they
have a deep sea of trauma and he thinks
that he's freeing them from life he
believes that he's setting people free
from all the anguish they've experienced
and this is actually mirrored in his
journey with eleven she's stuck in a
prison constantly bullied and he sees
allowing her to escape as something of
the utmost importance to him this is
likely reflected in the victims he
chooses namely max who's still feeling
the guilt over the death of billy but
him yes said it he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and i killed sparky too now i think we
will likely discover this and also his
end game which is to invade our world we
learn that the upside down works very
much as a hive mind and that he has a
legion of bat-like monsters ready to
swarm hawkins after cutting a tear
between the realities i think that he
will unleash all of these which will be
a major part of volume two so add that
add that one yeah beckoners plan and
that's what's gonna happen you damn
chump see ya chump
now in order to counter this i think
that brenner has been working on his own
plan we know that he studied becca when
he was a child and that he very much
found a way to inhibit his abilities i
think brenner has been brought back for
a very important reason and that he
wanted to study 11's powers once more so
that he could find a way to permanently
stop her abilities and the upside down
guy seems like he might have actually
changed and after opening pandora's box
he could end up wanting to close it
lastly i think the most obvious one is
that hopper and co will get back to
america his first volume was very much
about rescuing him from the hell that is
kamchatka so i think next time will be
about him getting back to the us i'd
love to see him back before the end of
the season but i think that vol 2 will
probably end with him finally touching
down in hawkins from there season 5 can
bring him back to 11 and i think the
next spot will focus on them trying to
escape russia before they make it back
to the us think season 5 will just hit
the ground running and have all the
characters back in hawkins and i can
imagine this entry is very much just
going to be about pulling them back into
the area after the groups were split up
but then put that on screen somewhere if
you can and that's the final theory and
now i'm gonna pass it over to you what
do you think is gonna happen comment
below and let me know we are running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of the batman on the 15th
of june and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your predictions and theories
we picked the comments at random on the
15th and the winners of the last one on
screen right now so that's you then
message me on twitter at heavyspoilers
you want some emails to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of the
season which will be linked on screen
right now we go over the entire ending
and explain what happened so definitely
hit that video up right after this
without the way thanks for sending
through this one i've been poor i will
see you next time take care peace